Please let Weathergate put that person to sleep.
[Music] Please
leave it to me, Se-chan. We'll make
sure to overthrow the aniros that trouble Set-chan, who is different from the old, tired people.
Did you really hear that?  Pencilgon
In Unite Rounds, the Pencil Warrior who appeared as an NPC and made her a living creature that lured in
enemies, and who
hung an NPC princess on a chandelier and
made her a living creature that lured players,
has finally become a human being as an NPC.  I feel
like I've regained my heart. This is
how I feel. [Music] My heart [Music] I guess that's rude, isn't it? I'm trying to
imprint the violence at the upper limit of your level in my brain. Wait, wait, now I'm desperate.  It
's crazy how bad my eyes are.
[Music] If it hadn't been
before I tried it, I would have had to reskill it five times. It seems
like I'm back to being the usual Pencil Gon. It's a
little weird.
hey